saw this this morning we love Pat McAfee
we had him on where were we at the
combine he came in was and edible times
there was a Monday night football
opening and the booth and the rumor
started let's get pat on their hash tag
hash tag we were kind of spearheading
that great hashtag trending nationally
didn't get the job didn't get the job
there booger and test book and tests up
there but it's baby steps right it's
baby steps so breaking this morning Adam
Schefter broke it Thursday night college
football Pat McAfee in the booth yes
with Adam Amon Matt Hasselbeck Molly
McGrath on the sidelines so Pat is in
the booth ESPN
Thursday night college football you
believe that is is the man on the line
right now on the horn Patrick
congratulations Pat yeah boy
very excited about what happened today
for my life very pumped up for Thursday
night and I will forever forever and
ever be indebted to you guys for
launching that McAfee for Monday Night
Football run we didn't get it would have
been an aggressive decision but Thursday
nights will be just as fun I can't thank
you enough thanks for having me on how
are you guys I'm doing great Pat I don't
know is America ready for Pat McAfee on
West honey on a level like what you're
about to bring Pat what do you think
rich rich yes you know my mom's been
sick to me for like two decades now
right she's had me for too much of her
life is America's gonna feel the same
way as my mom we're all hoping not for
sure we're all hoping that isn't the
case but I do believe with you mix in a
little Matt Hasselbeck who has an
incredible brain for football good
friend of mine Adams gonna do an
incredible job guiding the train down
the track and I'm there just add you
know little quips a little bit of
knowledge in the fourth down a little
bit of chitter chatter about student
sections and things that are happening
and my job is just to make sure that
people have a good time when they watch
the game on Thursday nights and had a
little knowledge but well people hate me
I assume so I mean I assume that's gonna
happen come on Pat you're America's
Sweetheart we all know that
but so are there gonna be any times that
you give a little bit of experience of
your time at West Virginia trying to
tell Bill Polian about whether you're
able to hold or punt and kick and all of
that stuff Pat are you gonna be able to
I think it I think it's gonna be a big
do as I say not as I do
type situation you know I mean I lied to
Bill Polian I told that story right here
on the beautiful wrist eyes and show
before you became a bleacher report live
show by the way congrats on the big move
Thank You Pat oh thank you I would not I
would not hope that the young kids of
today would follow my lead in that
particular realm but I've had a chance
to be a part of one of the greatest
college football teams of all time I got
a chance to ride coattails into very
cool situations we had a lot of
celebrating obviously we won a lot and I
think I'll lean on those experiences
often in the games and I I think I am
very pumped to be back in the college
football world just the passion the
games the environment just everything is
awesome the history of the tradition and
I think it's gonna really team me up
nicely for my type of personality and my
brain but we'll see how it goes
obviously then you and you and Matthew
or you go way back to the Colt to your
Colts days together right in hassle you
know Matt Hasselbeck was my first ever
guest on my local newspaper show I had
here he attended the red carpet premiere
here in Indianapolis of my first
stand-up special Matt and I chatted
about life often he's a good friend of
mine and I think he was a pretty big
driving force and this whole thing
coming to be to be honest I think he
pitched guard for me to join him in
there and I'm pumped up man he's big and
bald and he's very smart and he has an
incredible resume and I hope I can draw
some things out of that brain of his
that really put him over the top and
calling games because I love that man
and it'll be an honor to get back in
there will be shower and obviously I
don't think we'll be sweating but it'll
be nice to get back in the locker room
with old Matt Hasselbeck get out there
in the trenches and really win some
games serious question though powder you
give
everything else that you're doing or you
gonna still do it your show oh no rich
oh no ok we I was gonna go kick for an
NFL team I was gonna go place kick for
an NFL team I was asked if I wanted to
get back into the kicking world and
since I didn't get the Monday Night
Football gig or any networks are really
reaching out to me I was like alright
I'll just go back to the NFL like I'm
Jason Witt so I thought I was going to
go back kick some balls place kick for a
team put it for through a full couple
months training and then I went and did
a stress test for the team basically
kicking a bunch punting and kicking off
a bunch and while I was on the plane
back home this is like two and a half
weeks ago while I was on the plane back
home my knee that I got surgery on my
last year in the NFL it just ballooned
out of nowhere it was like Antonio Brown
could have hopped on the bottom of my my
knee and fluid into Napa Valley 24 miles
away for training camp I mean it just
blew up and I couldn't even get up to go
pee on that plane and it was a nice
peaceful moment of closure for me that I
performed well but it seems as if my
body has other plans and I texted my
people because you know I have people
now in big time and I said hey I think
we're getting back into the media world
and they said sounds good
get ready for a whirlwind so the last
couple of weeks have been just trying to
figure out the fall schedule and right
now everybody liked me everybody who's
made deals that may have been shaking a
lot of hands but nobody got me
exclusively because they didn't like me
that much so I mean I'm gonna have a
pretty busy fall but I'm very excited
for it okay spud I'm your podcast are
you still doing that or that's going to
be under the ESPN banner Pat are you all
in
that'll be a part of Pat McAfee Inc my
brother very very very Simmons like Pat
I mean they're very you know like
normally you go lock stock in every
barrel but then again you know we're all
talking about for the brand a lot of the
conversation on your show not very uh
very worldwide leader
brand like sometimes now there it's I
don't I don't think of passport to fun
and Disney sometimes when I'm on your
program pad I mean you can get the bunny
pass or whatever it isn't listen to my
show I talk to adults about adult things
but I nobody really wanted to everybody
liked me so I'm getting a lot of great
deal offers like for instance ESPN likes
me
and I'm very lucky for the opportunity
they give me but they didn't want me for
everything right now so it's like yeah
we like them for this buddy so does this
so I'm getting a chance to kind of do my
own thing still while getting incredible
opportunities to kind of hopefully do
well and we'll see how it goes but fall
there's gonna be a lot of mcafee rich
there's gonna be a lot of McAfee and
literally I think I'm gonna get sick of
me but no man so have you revealed which
team you were you were flying and
working out for Pat have you revealed
that is that is that of an ape at McAfee
reveal yet well I mean I refuse to say
the name of the team because I don't
want to give it up but it's like the
third largest city in America yeah and
I've had a little bit of a thicker
situation and named after an animal
there's a nickname of an animal that you
can sometimes see in a zoo Pat yep it's
a big scary one it's a big scary one got
it if you run into it in the woods it's
probably gone through your garbage and
last year they had a little bit of a
kicking situation at the end of the year
old joint joint and they're kicking
consultants they hired a kicking
consultant he was my kicking coach back
in the day and he just asked me he's
like hey you ever think about
place-kicking because I was a
placekicker in college all-time leading
scorer at West Virginia no big deal was
on a great team but I wasn't good enough
to kick in the NFL I learned that after
watching Adam Vinatieri but after
kicking with Bennett Terry for eight
years and getting a chance to kind of
learn from the greatest of all time my
field goal kicking it up pretty good but
the only people that knew it were the
people that were either at practice or
know me from before
so the that situation with the lions and
tigers and the it really
my servo my coach is a d-- coordinator
there and my kicking coach was there so
and they're like hey you think you still
got it I gave it a go and the needs that
no no brother you were not so I'm
disappointed in that I think Hine said
I'll be upset with my me but right now
I'm just hitting the ground running with
some media stuff well Pat I'm so excited
for you you know what they should do
they should send you into a college
campus a couple days before you're going
in there to do the game and they should
dress you up like the sort of like
Knoxville like you did as the elderly
gentleman kicking kicking balls and just
send you out into campus doing all sorts
of stuff and seeing how the kids react
to you I mean I'd love to see that I'd
love to see you know you with a marching
band just be in Pat McAfee on a college
campus I think would be amazing before
hearing your your stylings in the booth
I can't wait bud
I'll be great you know rich hey we might
put you on the payroll there for your
brain those are good creative content
ideas right there my report I did know
yet still I mean look I used to be on
the payroll there for seven years Pat
you know and I also know the guy exactly
who is the one who's gonna call you up
if you say something a little out of
line I know exactly that I know that
office actually very well I've been in
that position what is the what is the
proper way to go in there you just kind
of go in there like if the principal's
office yeah gonna head down maybe wear a
nice suit
there's just go in and just go I know I
know I promise I get it that's it those
words that's it
you know I've been called into the
principal's office in my last profession
and I did not handle it in that and I I
think I think I'll learn from the past
and hopefully the future will be better
you and Hasselbeck are gonna be great
man great people good dudes and congrats
bud Congrats hey I appreciate you all so
much
you're so kind to me you allow me on the
air you've been pushing me for a long
time and the call you gave me earlier
today is one that I'll carry near and
dear to my heart forever and I can't
thank you enough man Congrats on
everything all of your success in
hopefully I won't be getting called in
the principal's office for making any
dumb Eisen moves but I'll be excited to
see how it goes okay and I just wanted
to appreciate it anytime you need me Pat
I'm there for you as you know and I just
needed to get you on the phone before I
got the the the drill of like I got a I
got a ask the SPN people if it's okay to
go on your show so I had to get in while
the gettin's good Pat I didn't even
think about that sorry then that's your
first pitch again just go I know I know
I promise I get it
that's it that's it that's good that's
it I'm in so much trouble
that's gonna be a lot to learn here with
these big Network stuff but hopefully
we'll navigate it through you know
you're the best every once in a while
blind squirrel find it nut that's what
we're pulling for here you're the best
chat soon padlock brother you're the man
that's Pat McAfee everybody for more of
the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
Live or download the Rich Eisen show app